ejercer su derecho a la desobediencia
civil algo que los ciudadanos ya no
pueden hacer en su propio país
los bien los rusos que viven en exilio
en ucrania conmemoran a los fallecidos
en las inéditas protestas del año pasado
y para impulsar el cambio no hay leyes
no hay derechos humanos en este país
todo el sistema es un problema y
necesita ser demolido por completo
el gobierno legal no nos quiere escuchar
pero estoy seguro de que los bien los
rusos viviendo en el exterior seguirán
presionando mucho en la elección
presidencial del año pasado los bien los
rusos vieron alexandr lukashenko con un
estilo autoritario reconocido por el
mismo declarar su victoria pero las
protestas masivas presentaron un desafío
sin precedentes a sus casi tres décadas
de gobierno y él respondió utilizando la
fuerza bruta
su principal rival en la elección
svetlana tica no es que haya en
reemplazo de su esposo preso se exilió
en lituania
desde la votación lukashenko tomó
medidas drásticas como limitar el
trabajo de los periodistas
independientes y también cerró docenas
de ongs y grupos de derechos humanos
llamando los bandidos y agentes
extranjeros
en mayo aviones de combate bielorruso se
interceptaron un vuelo comercial en el
que viajaba un periodista crítico del
gobierno y lo forzaron a aterrizar en
minsk el periodista román protege bits y
su novia fueron arrestados
el nivel de represión del régimen se vio
expuesto recientemente en los juegos
olímpicos de tokio la velocista cristina
sim anuska ya se negó a volver a su país
por temor a su seguridad luego de
criticar a miembros de su equipo en los
olímpicos